よろしくお願いします
で 前回からこの普通の心と違って
超自然的な いわゆる普通の心のレベルを超越したところの次元の説明に入ってるんです
色界という禅定の心に入っていって
1番目の心のことは説明いたしました
で まあ一応この前も申し上げましたけど
まあこの前の勉強会と
これから出てくる心の説明っていうのは
一般的な常識では決して理解できるものではありません
で どうしても心のレベルを乗り越えている
普通の心のレベルを乗り越える
乗り越えている世界なんです
で 私たち人間っていうのは
人間に生まれたら この三次元という
まあそれは仏教では三次元という言葉を使ってませんだけど
まあ現代的な科学の世界でも三次元という言葉ありまして
この三次元的な世界に我々は閉じ込まれ
閉じ込まれているんですね
で どういうことかというと
我々私たちにはこの眼耳鼻舌身という 5つの情報が入るチャンネルが 5つ付いているんですね
耳と鼻と目と目と舌と体の観測という
その 5つの窓口から入る情報を我々は知識だと思っているんです
そこでヨーロッパでは言わないんだけど
仏教ではやっぱりその 5つじゃなくて 6つのチャネルがあるんだと言ってるんですね
ヨーロッパだったら五根
ファイセンセスしかヨーロッパの心理学では出てこないんですね
ですから まあファイセンセスと
で ヨーロッパの心理学ではシックスセンスと言ったならば
それは特別な意味意味するんですね
で だいたいシックスセンスと書くんです
6じゃなくてこうやって書くんですね 6
番目のという意味で ですから
こっちに the 入れなくちゃいけないんですね
The sixth sense と
文法的には そこでヨーロッパ心理学では
6番目の認識器官というのは
それは超しているものだと
普通の人間には五根しかないとと思ってるんですね
で そこでエクストラセンサリーとか
まあいろいろ言葉使って
またギリシャの字で これサイですか
サイフェカリティというね
サイっていうのはまあ PSY かな PHY かな
まああまり薬は不得意ですが
H は サイフェカリティと読むんですね
まあそういう専門用語だからどうでもいいんですけど
そういう概念ありますけど
それとまた私たちの世界で言ってることはまた区別しなきゃいけないんですね
で そのヨーロッパで言ってるこの 6番目の目というのは
本当はあまり科学的に合理的にしっかり説明してないんです
だから科学者であるならばしっかり説明してほしいんだけど
そこら辺しっかり説明してないんです
ただ大雑把に何か現象があったら
そこはまあ 6番目の目だと言って
よく大騒ぎはしているんです
で 仏教側見ると 我々には五根があることは確かなんですね
眼耳鼻舌身 そこから入る情報をそのまま入っても知識にはならないんですと
見たものは見たそれだけ
聞いたものは聞いたそれだけですと
味わったものは味わった
それだけなんですね そこで我々はこの得た情報をどこかで処理しているんですね
いろいろ概念化して並べたり
あの えっと 正当 なんて言いますか
組織化したり 五根から入った情報を処理する処理場があるんですよ
それは仏教で 6番目の意なんですね
ですから ヨーロッパで五根というものと
仏教だったら同じレベルは六根と言うんです
で 私も不思議に思うのは
やっぱり人間っていうのは目で見てそれで止まるんじゃなくて
それについて考える それは明確なんですね
耳に入った音が耳にから音が入ったら
音について考える そこで考えたものについてさらに考えるという働きは常に持ってるんですね
それは否定する人はいませんし
それなのに それなのに
なんで六根という言葉が出てこないかと
ヨーロッパでは そこ不思議なんですね
6番目の認識機能というのは当たり前
明確ですのに ですからまあそこら辺差があるんです
ですから 心理学として
ヴィダルの心理学もいろいろガタガタのところありますけど
それはヨーロッパの心理学にしても同じことでということなんです
で 六根があります この六根がありますけど
不思議なこと 我々頭で考えているものはすべて客観的に見ると
いつか五根から流行った情報なんですね
人間いくら考えたっても
もう超越したものは考えられないんです
あっちこっち組み合わせるだけ
夢と同じなんですね 夢っていうのは
みんな不思議な夢見たとか
あれだけど思うでしょ
全然不思議な夢見ないんです
日常で起きたいろんな経験
眼耳鼻舌身から体現したもので
それについて受けた感情と
もう非合理的に組み合わせちゃう
頭の中で寝たところで
ただそれだけ 例えば 日頃は蛇が見たことがあると
それ日頃で見る蛇はごく普通の蛇かもしれません
蛇を見て驚いたと 怖くなった
それはもう子供の時見たかもしれませんし
で それはもう頭の中で蓄積されているし
ある日ものすごい巨大な蛇が夢で見るかもしれません
そうすると決して存在しないぐらいの大きな
ものすごい長い長い もう 10メートルじゃなくて 20メートル
40メートルぐらい長い
またすごい体太い蛇が見たんだと
夢で これはどういう意味ありますかとか
みんなまあすごい不安になったりして占ってもらったりはするんですね
でも普通に考えちゃうと
その人はどこかで蛇を見たりして
それで驚いたりしてとかね
その驚いたことを映像化されているんですね
夢の中で 映像化して ただ再現する
何でも夢の中で可能なんです
いわゆる情報ある脳の中で
それは混労しないで取り出す
図書館に例える 図書館というのはいろんな本がありますよ
図書館使う人は 自分勉強したい分野の本だけ選んで読むと
そうすると図書館との役に立ちます
その何も ある日何も決めないで
暇つぶしに図書館に行って
あっちから本一つ取って開けてみて
また下りて またこっちから一つ取って開けてみたり
またそうやっちゃうと
別に知識というものは頭に入るわけじゃないんですね
むさぼるように手当たり次第本を取って開けただけなんですね
夢ってだいたいそんなもんなんです
頭の中に入っている情報は
まああっちからどっちからどっちでもいいんだからね
まあ取って合わせちゃう
組み合わせちゃう ですから
夢の中ではゾウが飛ぶのは当たり前
もう可能なんですね なぜならば飛ぶという情報は頭の中にあるし
ゾウという情報も頭の中にあるし
その 2つ繋がればそれだけのことなんです
でも目が覚めている状態ではそれをしません
なぜならば 知識ということで
論理ということで それをコントロールしているんですね
その合理的な 寝たらもうなくなっちゃうんです
でもそれ働かしちゃうと
寝ても夢が見ても しっかり物事を具体的に
合理的に 客観的に 科学的に見ようではないかという脳にすいちゃったら
変な夢は見ないんです
全部それで消えちゃうんです
夢を見ても全く目が覚めている状態で見るような
きちんとした合理的な夢になるんです
ですから 夢の分析と夢を占ってもらう必要は全くそれで消えちゃうんです
で あまり意味がないんです
夢の分析と夢のどういう意味ですかっていうことは
あまり意味がない 全く意味がないわけじゃなくて
なぜならば いろいろ感情的な
いろんなショックを受けたりする人にとっては
その受けたショックは落ち着いてない限りは夢で出てくるんですね
私でも 例えば全く新しい知識やら
今まで聞いたことないこととか
なんとか頭に入っちゃったら
いきなり頭に入れちゃうんですね
入れておくだけで忙しくて整理できないんです
整理するため時間かかっちゃうんです
自分のものになるためには
もしそのまま寝ちゃったら
入れた情報全部片っ端からまた頭の中から出ちゃうんですね
それは夢といえば夢なんですね
夢で起きてた時 聞いたこと
勉強したことは全部出てきて
またどんどんどんどん落ち着いて中に入って入り込んじゃう
一旦入り込んじゃったらもう整理してるんです
だから自動処理 自動処理で
それはすごい便利なことで
あまり苦労しなくても
普通だったら勉強したものは考えて考えて整理しなきゃいけないんですけどね
どっちでも暇あれば自分でやりますけど
暇がなかったら寝ちゃえば自動的にちゃんと整理してくれるんです
だから夢を見ながらもう考えちゃう
この間聞いたあのことですね
今出てくるのは とかね
で あ これとかこうなったのはこういうわけです
こうなったのはこういうわけですよ
とかね それで一旦入っちゃったら
もうそこで不安定な状態は落ち着くんです
ですから普通我々はもう何か感情的なことがあったら
何か恥ずかしい目に遭ったりとかね
そういうものがあったら
すごく不安定になっちゃうの
精神状態が 不安定になりますから
それは夢で出てくるんですね
あるいは全くわからない質問されたりとかね
何か自分にはもう返事できない
反応できない場面に出会ったら
なんとなく悔しいようなものが残っちゃうんですね
その残ったエネルギーに刺激されて
脳内 頭の中に蓄積されている情報がどんどんもうコントロールなしに出てくる
それは夢と言うんですね
ですから いくらか夢を分析すると
その人の精神状態がわからないわけじゃないんです
本人の知識だから だからって
そんなにそれに執着する必要ないんです
夢に執着すると それは問題になっちゃうんですね
なんで私はこんな夢を見たんだろうとかね
これはどういう意味あるんだろうとかね
言って 夢の分析の本なんか読んだりすると
そこで問題が起こるんですね
そうでない限りは忘れちゃえばいいんです
どんな夢でも で また夢でこの
そういう逆説ですか そういう現象が起こるんです
というのは 逆説っていうのは
生きている時では 起きている時では
こうなってほしい こうなってほしくないという人間の希望があるんですね
夢でそれは逆になっちゃうんですね
なってほしいものの反対になっちゃうんですね
例えば試験に合格しようとして勉強する
人の希望は徹底的に合格したいってことですね
その人は夢を見ると 試験はもう合格どころじゃなくて
もうとんでもない全然答えがかけなかったとか
あるいは試験に行ってるんだけど
書く道具を忘れているとかね
あるいは試験場に あれ
何て言いますか あのカードありますね
入る 受験カードとか それを忘れたとかね
それでものすごい精神的なショックを受けたりとかね
そういうふうな夢を見たりはするんですよ
それは逆説で ことでなんでそうなりますかというと
それを占ってみるんだ
あなた 夢で試験は失敗しましたから
確実に合格するよとかね
占ってくる人々はいますけどもね
何の意味もないんです
どういうことかというと
合格したい したいと思うたびに
この論理っていうのは
あの 何て言いますか  2つで組み合わせるんですね
何て言いますか この反論ですか
いつでも論というのは反論で組み立ててるんですね
それは事実の世界なんですからね
試験は合格したいという場合は
落第するという事実があって
その上に合格という現象が成り立っちゃうんですね
健康的にいたい 健康になりたいという場合は
病気になるという土台があって
その上にそれ成り立ってるんです
ですから いつでも正と反のセットで物事できてるんです
あまり一つだけいじっちゃうといじっちゃうと
夢で逆のことが見えてくるんです
なぜならば 合格したい
合格したいと思うたびに
頭の中でもう落第したらどうしよう
落第したらどうしようということを活動しているんです
そこは夢で自由だから
そこら辺活動してくれるんです
そこで本人が大変心配したり
悩んだり 夢の中で苦しがったりはするんですね
だから そういうぐらいのことで
ちょっとしたゲームみたいなもんなんですよ
あまり意味がないんです
とにかく夢の話じゃないんだから
あの 6番目のこの意の意という意根の中で
我々は物事を考えたりする
私は言いたがっているのは
夢の中ででも たとえもうありえないものを見たっても
それ切ってバラバラにしてみると
我々の日常生活の中で五根から得た情報なんです
それ以上のものは体験しないんです
そこだけ考えてほしいんです
考えて理解して このあまりこの余計ない
この夢の分析とかね まあ夢占いとかね
夢の解釈とかね そこら辺にはそんなに囚われる必要はないんですよ
ちょっと笑ってごまかしておけば
それぐらいでももう済むもんなんです
それほど大変なことじゃないんです
人は夢見るということは
事実それだけのことなんです
で 私たちはこの眼耳鼻舌身という五根から情報を得る
その情報を頭の中で処理をする
それに知識という妄想ともいう
考えてるともいう 論理
合理 科学 すべてはこの五根から入る情報の脳細胞の処理なんですね
そこで一つ答えが出てくるんです
どういう答えかというと
人間はどんな偉いことを考えたっても
どんな立派なことを創造したっても
結局五根から入る情報の次元を超えてないということなんです
いわゆる次元の中に閉じ込められているんです
わかりやすく言えば 人間には決して神様なんかは体験することは不可能なんです
神様が現れて見たんですよという人も
結局は五根から入る情報を処理しているだけなんですね
で どこかのいろんな国々にいますね
神様現れました 見えましたとかね
アペリションというんで
特別な英語の言葉もあります
あるある人には神様が見えてきましたと
だいたい神様というよりはマリア様ですね
見えるのは そういう風に見えてきましたと
言ったら 人はその人はそれを信じているかもしれませんだけど
パッとクールな心で見ると
その人はもし本当に見たと思う場合は
その人は目で見たんですね
自分の目で見たものなんですね
その本人が自分の五根の次元を超えたかというと
超えてないんです 科学的に見ると
目で見えるものはもう知られているんですよ
何を目で見えるかと 目で見えるもの
目には入る情報はもう
決まっていて コントロールされていて
ある波動の中の光しか目で見えないんですね
ですから いくら神様が現れてきて見たと思ったっても
もっと科学的に分析してみると
我々見ているものと同じこと見ただけのことなんですね
特別な情報が入ったわけじゃないんです
なぜならば 目で見たんだから
目に目から入る情報っていうのは
どんな人間にも同じ範囲の中の情報しか見えないんです
そこで 音の場合も同じことで
耳で聞いたと言ったっても
まあ耳からちゃんと聞いたならば
まあそれは音の情報で
ですから この 一応一般的にはね
人間がどんな高度なこと
どんな宇宙のことを考えたっても
それ全て眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報の処理を通して考えられるんですね
眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報
それは物質的なエネルギーなんですね
目から入るものも 耳から入るものも
舌から体から入るものも
全部物質エネルギーなんですね
だから我々知っている物質は三次元的なんですね
本当は三次元でない 例えば電波とかも三次元じゃないんだけど
光も三次元かどうかちょっと分かりにくいんだけどね
まあ光には方向性がありますから
ほぼ二次元的に見えます
感じますけど 電波なんかは二次元で三次元でもないんですね
でも電波は残念ながら認識できないんです
例えば携帯電話でこちらで電話番号押しちゃったら
瞬時に多次元的にその電波を広げちゃうんですね
それは他の電話でその電波を受けますけど
だからってその電波は直接あの電話機まで届いたというと
そうじゃないんです もう一つの携帯電話を持ってる人はどこにでもつなげますからね
そうすると一方的に電波流れるんじゃなくて
いきなりパッと広げるんですね
どこにでも 上も下も横にもどこにでも
それまた瞬時に広げちゃう
時間的にはちょっと遅くなるということはありますけど
距離としては ですから
でもそういう風なエネルギーは私たち人間には認識できない
だから電波あることは人間知りません
全然知らないんです 電波というものあるということは
我々知っているのは もう自分の携帯電話が鳴っていると
誰かメッセージが入ったということだけなの
それは耳で聞いて聞くんだから
私たち知っているのは耳から入る情報だけなんです
音だけなんです 電波を聞くことはできない
もし電波が聞こえるならば
もう生活できなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならこの空気中にどれほど電波があるかというと
まあ遊びで亡くなっちゃうんです
すぐ死ぬかもしれません
あまりにもいろんなものを
もういろんな音やらね
いろんな映像やら もう全部もうまたがってもう流れてますからね
まあそういうことだから
そこら辺はしっかりしてほしいんですね
人間に認識できる世界はもうすごい決まってるんだと
そこで私たちの知識もその三次元の三次元の中に閉じ込められているんです
だから 人間がいくら考えても妄想すること
思索すること 考えること
想像すること いくら働かせても三次元の中
ですから 人間 書く文章やら知識やら哲学やら
だいたい修行なしにわかるんです
ですから 人間に勉強できない知識とか何かあること全然ないんです
勉強すれば何でもできるんです
なぜならば もう三次元の中の話ですからね
例えば勉強していないんだから
我々は数学のことを知らないかもしれません
数学のプロもものすごい人々がいますけど
もしその人が書いた論文でもあろうとも
もうそれなりに適当に勉強して
概念を頭に入れて入れておけば
もうわかるようになってしまうんです
特別な修行なしに 単なるこの情報はどのように並べているかということだけなんです
ですから 世の中でそんなに大胆な知識というものがあるわけじゃないんです
我々は毎日得ている体験
いろんな人は自分のやり方で整理する
今 世の中で社会学やら人類学とか分野あるんですよ
人類学といったら それは難しい分野で
大学なんかに入って特別訓練を受けないとわからないと
言ってるし 人類学者が使っている言葉っていうのは一番難しい言葉
分かりにくいんですね
新しい言葉をどんどん作っちゃうんです
そこでみんな驚くんです
ああ すごい わからない
すごい難しい分野だ 何のこともないんです
人類学っていうのは 我々日常生活でどうやって生きてるかっていうことだけなんですね
それはある人々は人間に訳も分からない概念使って
それ概念の中で整理しているだけ
例えばシンクレティシズムという言葉があるんです
辞書を引いても出てこないんです
シンクレティシズムという言葉なんか
どういうことかというと
人間が生きている場合は
例えば日本人が日本文化の中に生きていて
そこで日本にヨーロッパの文明が入る
入っちゃったら ヨーロッパ文明の仕来り習慣というのはあくまでも外来文化だから
なんかちょっとした違和感があるんですね
そこで それでも向こうの方が格好いいんだから
こちらで受け入れたいんですね
受け入れられて受け入れちゃったら
なんとなくいきなりみんなにちょっとあんた変ではないかと言われちゃうんですね
なぜならば日本文化じゃないんだから
そこでシンクレティシズムという働きが起こるんだと
いわゆる日本化になっちゃうんですね
外国の習慣なんですけど
なんとなく日本の習慣になる
その日本の習慣になったものは
決して日本の習慣でもなく
ヨーロッパの習慣でもない
どっちでもないものになっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなことは毎日あることなんです
例えば もう日本語でカタカナ語いっぱいあるでしょうに
ほとんど英語から貰うもんだけど
全然英語じゃないんですね
一旦カタカナになったら
ああいう風な現象 だから毎日経験していることに
その人類学者が特別な言葉を使う
ソーシャルシンクレティシズムとかなんとかとかね
それで はぁまあこれは勉強しなくちゃいけないかなと
よく見ると何のこともないことなんですよ
ああ そんなもんだと ですから
この まあちょっと我々も勉強すると
こういう立場ちょっと変えちゃうとすごい勉強しやすいんです
この認識っていうのはどんなものは
なるほど この眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報が頭の中でいろいろやり方で処理しているだけですよと
この先生はどのように処理しているんですかと
その入る情報が その先生の処理のやり方を理解しちゃえば
もう全部勉強したことになっちゃうんです
すごい早く まあそこはまた余計な話なんですけど
で じゃあ一応とりあえず理解しておきましょう
我々の知識も論理も すべては三次元のレベルで閉じ込められて閉じ込められているんだと
そういうことで かなりの努力をしないと
超次元的な認識過程は生まれないんですね
で 超次元的な認識過程生まれないように
我々の心が何かハンディ持ってるんです
ハンディっていうのはシンクレティック言葉で
これはハンディキャップなんですね
英語で意味が で まあちょっとした心のハンディがあるんですね
障害 その障害を何とかすると
何とかその障害を乗り越えちゃうと
この邪魔されているこの壁を何とかすると
心には何のことなく 三次元の枠を破って超越した
超越した次元の いわゆる超次元の世界を認識することができるのです
これはどういうハンディかというと
この心の回転 ここから考えましょう
心がいつでも認識するという回転を行っているんですね
それは生きているという意味なんですね
いわゆる生きているということは
心が動いているという意味なんです
心っていうのは認識すること
別に対した心があるわけでもないんです
例えば ある物体が生きているというならば
その物体に外の世界はわかるんです
だから生きていると言うんです
例えば このメガネケースは生きてないんです
このメガネのケースが外の世界は全然わからない
こちらに虫 一匹止まったら
この虫が生きているんですね
なぜならば その虫が外の世界はわかるんです
私は虫を触ろうとしたら虫が逃げるということは
私に触れたことは虫が知ってるんです
知ってて これ危ないと
逃げましょうと判断して逃げる
だから虫が生きている
虫には心がある ミミズにはだから心がある
環境は判断しているんだから
それは心 ですから 生きる生きているためには心が活動しなくちゃダメ
活動する必要は確実にある
でも心っていうのは確実に回転する
どんな理由 訳があっても止まることは全然不可能なんです
呼吸なんかは止まって見れる
止まることできますよ
心臓でも止まる 止まることできます
お医者さんなんかは平気で心臓止まっちゃいますから
この心臓の手術する場合は
お医者さんもそういうある日
一応話を聞いてみたんですね
どうやってやるんですか？そしたらもうなんかもうなんかすごい失礼な言葉で
まあこうやって切って
こうやって骨を開けて
こういう機械でこうやって開けて
それから心臓の上にいっぱい氷をいっぱい氷を入れちゃって
心臓を止まってもらうんだと
だからなんで止まってもらうんだろう
これむちゃくちゃ動くと
もうめんどくさい できない仕事できないんだと
ですから平気で止まって
それから手術して それからいくらか温めて
電気ショックですか 電気ショックで動かして
それからもう全部縫っておくんだと
言ったら なんかこの人たちはね
人の大事な心臓なんかもうなんかおもちゃのおもちゃ扱いしてるんではないかと
まあそのお医者さんの話を聞きながらそう思ったんだけどということなんで
結局は 心臓もまあ我々別に手術じゃなくても止まる時ありますからね
で じゃあだから心が止まることができますかと言えば
それはできないんです
それはどうしても回転するんです
回転するためにはエネルギーが必要なんです
そのエネルギーは認識する対象なんです
ですから 目から入る情報は心に生きるためのエネルギーなんですね
命のエネルギーなんです
耳から入る情報も命のエネルギーなんです
舌から入る情報も 食べるご飯は命のエネルギーじゃないんです
あれは機械に必要な部品だけなんですけど
でも舌から入る味わう
味わうこと 味覚は生きるために必要なエネルギーなんです
味覚というんですか？味覚
味覚 そういうのは心回転するために必要なエネルギーなんです
ですから皆様でもやっぱりもう元気がなくなったところで
どうか外へ行ったりとか
公園に行ったりとか みんな遊んでるところに行っちゃったら元気になるんじゃないんですか
なぜならば 耳から音は入る
目から情報が入る そこで心はまた元気よく回転する
それで元気になったよというだけ
で やることなくなってると
なんかどんどんつまらなくなっちゃうでしょ
それは刺激がないんだからなんですね
じゃあだからって人は死ぬんですかね
それはないです 見るものもないし
やる仕事もないし 聞きたい音もない場合は
あまり食欲もないし 食べたくもないしと
そうするとどんどんつまらなくなって
すごい暗くなる それで命のエネルギーが消えちゃうでしょ
命のエネルギー消えたら死ぬはずなんですが
死なないんですね その代わりに心が違うエネルギーを得られるんです
なぜならば 今つまらないんだと
今人生すごい退屈だと
それはエネルギーになるんです
ああ 嫌だとかね あるいはもう自分のことを妄想する
まあどうせ私は不幸だからとかね
そういう悲観的な ネガティブ的な妄想でもして心を回転させちゃうんです
止まらないんです だからこの人はネガティブ思考が始まっちゃったら止まらないでしょうに
あんた明るく考えなさいと言ったって
すぐネガティブになってしまっちゃう
なぜならば そこら辺で簡単に生命エネルギー得ているんだから
慣れてるんだから で それがもう一つの心の法則で
心は止まらないこと どう頑張っても
それはなんで言ったんですかというと
私たちが死にたくない
死ぬのは怖いという考え方があるんです
そういうのは理屈はないんです
なぜ死にたくないんですか？他のものにはちゃんと理由があるんですよ
例えば火遊びは危ないんだと
それは経験があるんだから
もうちゃんと知っている
地震は怖いと それはちゃんと合理的なんです
そこで死ぬのは怖いという人は
何も合理的じゃないんです
何の経験もない 自分知ってるのは
他の人死ぬことは知ってますけど
おじいちゃん死んじゃったんだから
私は死ぬのは怖いですよと言ったっても
それはおじいさんそれで死んで悪かったかどうか分からないでしょうに
死ぬのはきついかないか分からないでしょうにね
単なる心が死ぬのは怖いということを覚えているんですね
死にたくないと  それにも理由はあるんです
なぜならば 我々は輪廻の中で数え切れないほど死んできたんだからね
ですから経験はあるんです
死ぬたびに悔しいんです
ものすごく せっかく元気よく気持ちよく生きていたのに死んじゃうんですね
それですごい悔しいんですね
あの悔しさから 死ぬのは嫌だなと思っちゃうんです
この世の中で本当に素晴らしい
幸福で幸福に満ち溢れて
親戚 子供たちと家族とがああだこうだとかね
お金もあって 社会的な立場もあってとか
そこで突然死んでしまっちゃうし
せっかく居心地よく生きてたのに死んでしまっちゃいますから
すごい悔しいんですね
まあそれは仏教で言うドゥッカであって
不満なんですね だから死ぬのは嫌だなという経験が生まれる瞬間に刷り込まれているんです
ですから 生まれることももう本当はもう嫌なんです
大きなお世話なんですよ
その生命に対しては 向こうにいたかったのに
強引に死なせて他のところに生まれさせるんですね
別にそこで産まれたならば
新しい生き方作らなくちゃいけないし
慣れているのは過去の生き方なんですね
ですから 生まれることも生命に対しては嫌な気持ちなんです
私たちはちょっと忘れているだけで
ということで 仏教では生もドゥッカであると
死もドゥッカであると
それは瞑想して自分の心の働きを見るとよくわかること
普通の仏教の本格人々は生まれたからいろいろ苦しみに出会うんだから
生はドゥッカですよとお釈迦様はおっしゃったんですよって偉そうなこと言うんですけど
それはもう普通の人間の考え方で
釈迦様の考え方じゃない
その本格人々が 自分にとっては別に生まれたことは別に不幸でも何でもなかったし
子供の時は結構楽しかったとかね
なんで釈迦さんが生はドゥッカであると言ってるんですかね？とか
あ なるほど 生まれてからいろいろ大変なことがあるんだから
それだったら あ なるほどと
あれは非合理的なんですね
それだったら生は苦しみの原因になるよというべきなんですね
生まれたから苦しみがあるんだよということで
お釈迦様 生じゃなくて生すなわちドゥッカと言うんでしょうんですね
お釈迦様 文法間違いを起こしてないんです
生すなわちドゥッカであると
生あるがゆえに苦しみがあるとは言ってないんです
それなのに仏教の本を読んでみてください
すぐああいう風な解釈しちゃうんです
それは人間の解釈で 聖者のお釈迦様の解釈じゃないんです
だから仏教の解釈の権利はね
まあ本当のいわゆる権利があるのはお釈迦様だけですからね
まあ生はドゥッカなんです
生すなわちドゥッカなんです
生まれるのは悔しくて生まれるんです
これでいいんですか？ということがそこであるんですね
でもやむを得ない 生まれなくちゃいけないんです
止まることは不可能なんです
エネルギーは止まれませんよ
物質的なエネルギーもそうですから
どんな風にエネルギーを破壊したっても
エネルギーは消えない
他の状態になって だからもう悔しくたってもしょうがないんです
それで一旦生まれたら
そんな簡単には死ねないんです
心はなんとか工夫して回転する
面白いものがない場合は
面白いものがないと悔しがって回転する
笑うことはなくなっちゃったら
泣くことで心が忙しくなっちゃう
何でもいいんです 心に
何か刺激さえあれば そこでちょっとした利口的な生き方っていうのは
まあ悪い刺激は捨てちゃって
強引にでもいい刺激の方に心ならず鳴らしておけば
人間は幸福に生きていられるんですよ
まあ解脱以外は幸福になるというのはものすごい至極簡単なことなんです
それは そんな大変なことじゃないんです
ただ 心の思考方向性 思考の方向性
それをポジティブに持っていくだけ
そんな大したことないんですよ
物事を明るく見る それだけ
ちょっとした変わり方
人に悪口 悪口を言われると
本当になんで私は悪口言われなくちゃいけないんですかとか考えちゃうと
苦いし それで不幸な方向で心回転する
逆に取れば 人が私のことを悪口に
それはその人の勝手だからね
勝手にやればいいんじゃないですかね
その人は自由だから もうこの自由な国で人を何言おうがその人は自由ですよと
そこでも他の友達がそう言ったっても
あなたのことみんな悪く思ってるんですよと
その人を言ってることを信じるならば
それはあなた方の自由ですよと
私は人ができているんだから
あなた方の自由は侵そうとしませんよと言ってしまえばそれだけのことでしょうね
例えば人が面と向かって私はあなた本当に信頼できる人だなと思ってますと言ったら
あ そうですか はい ありがとうございます
と言っちゃえば そこで問題終わりなんですよ
私に対してもいろいろ
もうずっと日本の人 いろんな批判やら話やら
もう結構流す 流しちゃった
いろんな人が 僕は一度もそれに反応しなかったんですね
正当化 自分の立場が正しいんだと一度も言わなかったんです
一人勝手に楽しがっていたんですね
一人で そこで私は悪人だと人が決めちゃったら
僕は一人で楽しいんですね
このバカが あの人いたからそんな
それを信じ込んじゃってね
苦しんでるのはその人であって
私じゃないんだと ですから
ただほんのちょっとだけのことで
心の方向性を明るく入れ替える
それだけで人間は究極的に幸福になるんですね
それを単純なことをおっしゃったら
それは商売にならないんだからね
世の中のみんな 幸福論というのはものすごい膨大な幸福論をいろいろ喋るんですよ
除霊しなくちゃいけないとかね
悪霊を追っ払わなくちゃいけないとか
ああだこうだ 毎日毎晩
毎朝毎晩お祈りしなくちゃいけないとかね
方向なんとかね  何て言いますか
あれは仕事に行く場合はちゃんと方向
方角 方角を見て ちゃんと行動しなくちゃいけないとかね
八卦 八卦占いでもしてもらわなきゃ
もう商売始めるなとかね
こんなものはどうでもいいんですよ
結局は 何も無視しちゃえばそれだけのことで